hello everybody I'm Ross or sauce I'm a
founder of the medical cannabis society
and on behalf of the cannabis Sciences
planning committee I want to welcome you
all to the first annual cannabis
Sciences virtual event as this is the
first ever cannabis virtual event we're
going to explore the current landscape
of cannabis including regulatory issues
standardization in cultivation and
extraction as well as testing and
analysis not to mention the numerous
presentations and panel discussions on
cannabis therapies as they are applied
to a wide range of diseases such as
cancer autism and pain management as far
as the technology goes is produced on a
new more robust platform that you can be
able to watch learn and connect during
this conference on mobile devices faster
and easier than ever before equipped
with a gamification and point system
your maila moved through the event and
pick up points for a chance to win one
of lab routes most popular t-shirts I
picked up talk nerdy to me today this is
an educational event and thus accredited
by pace continuing education please
watch the webcast presentations to earn
those seee credits of course this
conference couldn't happen without the
support of our sponsors so please take
the time to visit the vendor hall and
say thank you to each and every one of
them as well as check out the products
and services that they provide that make
our jobs easier so without much further
ado please enjoy the cannabis Sciences
virtual conference thank you